ايا يكن الدافع الانتقاله من مدريد الى
يوفنتوس فمعناه ان رونالدو يستطيع احراز
ارقام قياسيه جديده فاصبح انتقالا تاريخيا
الى ايطاليا سجل رقما قياسيا في انتقال
لاعب فوق سن الثلاثين فكان في الثلاثه من
العمر لكنه يحافظ على لياقه مذهله طبعا
واصبح مع يوفنتوس اول لاعب يفوز بلقب
الدوري في انجلترا واسبانيا وايطاليا
وتشعر بان رونالدو يجد ارقاما قياسيه
يستطيع تحطيمها ويوفنتوس المكان المناسب
لذلك
لسوء حظ رونالدو تعكر اول اداء له في دوري
الابطال مع يوفنتوس بتعرضه لطرد مثير
للجدال
لكن حتى بعدما مر به في مسيرته ما زالت
لدى رونالدو تلك النزعه الى المشاكسه وقد
رايناه في ظهوره الاول في دوري الابطال مع
يوفنتوس ضد فالنسيا حين تعرض للطرد على ما
يبدو بسبب شد شعر جيسون موريلو مدافعي
فالنسيا
قد يكون رونالدو في مازق رونالدو في ورطه
كبيره هذا دوري الابطال
سيتصدر الخبر العناوين العوده الاولى
لرونالدو الى اسبانيا منذ قياده ريال
مدريد تشهد طرد مسجل الارقام القياسيه في
دوري الابطال الاوروبي تحطم رونالدو تماما
وغادر الملعب باكيا كانت لحظه مهوله في
مسيرته الواعده مع يوفنتوس تلك اول بطاقه
حمراء ينالها في دوري الابطال لكنها
الحاديه عشره في مسيرته الرياضيه هناك
لحظات في مسيرته يعود فيها رونالدو ذلك
الطفل المتهور الذي لعب في صفوف مانشستر
يونايتد